What will the cars of the future look like?
For decades car companies and reporters
have tried to predict what kind of vehicles we'd be driving.
'This little chariot can really run you around
in circles'
Although some of these ideas may have come
up short,
what about the new buzz about the driverless car?
Driverless cars will be a fact of life sooner
rather than later.
Ford CEO Mark Field says that in five years
the company will be manufacturing fully autonomous vehicles,
Uber's already running self driving
taxis on an experimental basis in Pittsburgh
and Google for years has been experimenting
with a fully autonomous car in California,
but is all that just a lot of hype?
and how will it change infrastructure projects and transportation policy?
This is completely absurd.
That's Bob Poole,
the Searle Freedom Trust Transportation Fellow
and Director of Transportation Policy at Reason Foundation.
He sat down with Reason TV's editor in chief
Nick Gillespie
to answer a few questions about the future of autonomous vehicles.
So you're more skeptical about driverless
cars than most people, you know,
and that there'll become, fully autonomous cars will become the norm on American roads
in a short period of time.
Where's your skepticism coming from?
Skepticism is coming partly from researchers,
serious researchers,
not reporters, writing in the popular press, At UC Birkeley, at Carnegie Melon, at MIT
who say this is a much harder problem
than a lot of people, including Elon Musk, make it out to be.